i was thinking as i was biking home from
drop in toby at school yesterday
about the comparison just a thought
experiment that you know obviously one
can't know but i was thinking about the
comparison between bad news for you that
was today
really yeah wow okay you should start
over but just you know just i'm gonna
just mess with your timeline but i'm but
i'm telling you the truth that that was
today okay well
yeah um i remember it like it was
yesterday
wow
okay sorry guys start over um
but anyway i was thinking about the
comparison between
the response to the pandemic that we saw
which was
almost
unbelievably top-down
right
we had we had
remote bureaucrats interfering with the
relationship between
your doctor and your pharmacist right
your doctor was not allowed to prescribe
certain things even though under normal
circumstances the doctor can prescribe
whatever they want right so that's an
amazing level of top-down coordination
that basically
you know rendered uh
doctors and pharmacists as automatons in
some system that had decided on one one
path let me say anecdotally that i had a
conversation with a doctor whom i trust
this week
uh no i trust this doctor all the time
but i had the conversation this week and
i was reporting
uh my experience with covet a couple
weeks ago and reported that i had gotten
a prescription for uh hcq
and uh and this doctor whom i trust said
how did that prescription go through i
can't get it through i cannot get the
prescription put through and i'm
i think i'm not gonna explain it here
because i think it's probably not safe
to do so and that further tells you what
kind of a landscape we're living in
but the idea that a doctor should be
asking a patient
that you know how is it that some other
doctor was able to prescribe something
completely legitimately
uh when this has always been the prayer
view of doctors this is you know this is
one of the things you go to school for
is to gain some autonomy to to have this
sort of you know this stamp of approval
on your forehead that says you now know
enough
that we are going to vouch for the fact
that you are going to make decisions and
sometimes those decisions will harm
people and overall they will do people
good and you are able to make those
decisions for yourself and this
incredibly top-down top-down and just
remarkably like across the board
authoritarian response
took
took the power away from all of the
people who who have earned it and that
includes also of course the individuals
who don't have medical degrees who
wanted to be able to say um continue to
take supplements that they had been
taking before the the kinds of
supplements like nac that were yanked
from shelves
right um and you know what i what i
concluded is that i believe if doctors
had been left to their own devices right
if there had been no overarching
public health mandates of any kind at
any level and doctors had done what
doctors are trained to do which is to
treat patients that have
diseases that they can't be certain of
the nature of and to discover what works
right
doctors try things they try things based
on the fact that this set of symptoms
implies that this system is doing that
thing and these
you know drugs tend to be helpful in
those cases
doctors would do that they would
discover i mean as we discovered
you know ventilators seemed like the
thing right they weren't right doctors
figured that out but
the the point is you would expect
crude initial response to get rapidly
better on the f on the basis that
doctors are intelligent people who can
talk to each other pool information and
get smarter collectively rather than
have some thing in washington with
unknown allegiances dictating a response
and handing it down and then brow
beating and penalizing doctors for
departing from it which is what we saw
and i think
to my way of thinking it is essentially
certain that we would have lost fewer
people and we would have had a lot less
carnage
if doctors had been left to do the thing
that they
are in general left to do which is
access the pharmacopoeia among other
things and figure out what works
and presumably
be free
to put out their recommendations which
has has been noted for for many many
months many many times now it is
remarkable that there are almost no sets
of recommendations for either
prophylaxis or treatment for this
disease that's insane that is insane
there is a set
of um
stamped with the approval of of the
government and the pharmaceutical
companies
vaccines so called and there are a
couple of newly generated uh again
by the pharmaceutical companies drugs
and
nothing else is officially approved and
that's
there's never been a pathogen in the
history of the earth for which nothing
else that isn't brand new has worked
and even even though it is quite clear
at this point that this pathogen um was
helped in its evolution with with humans
that doesn't make it such a new thing
that it can only be treated with things
that have been created by humans
yeah um
there's there's no possibility that you
wouldn't find useful things to do
doctors around the world have come up
with different protocols you've got a
bunch of them that work and the point is
you also have a public health apparatus
swearing that they don't wear work
swearing that the doctors who have put
these are out are
cranks and that's just um abnormal and
frankly transparent right there is some
other priority here right that involves
disrupting normal medicine and you know
basically setting a precedent for uh
basically
allowing your government to stand in for
your doctor
yeah which is appalling
[Music]